alors la schl a décidé de limiter à 350
millions de dollars par institution
financière la valeur des prêts
hypothécaires titrisées pour le mois
d'août qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement
voici l'explication la banque par
exemple vous prête 200 mille dollars
pour acheter une maison c'est votre prêt
hypothécaire la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement va racheter
la créance de la banque et de 200 mille
dollars pour la transformer en titres de
créance qui sera revendue dans les
marchés financiers
en revendant la dette hypothécaire en
s'en débarrassant la banque a donc de
l'argent disponible pour faire d'autres
prêts hypothécaires pour l'achat
d'autres maisons
ce que la schl a donc décidé de faire
aujourd'hui c'est de limiter la valeur
des prêts hypothécaires qu'elle va
racheter pour éviter justement de
prendre trop de risques les banques
devront donc trouver de nouvelles
sources de financement c'est ce qu'on
vous disait des sources qui ne seront
pas garantis par la schl donc les
banques vont prendre plus de risques
plus de risques c'est plus d'intérêt à
payer et ça pourrait signifier
éventuellement une hausse des taux
hypothécaires d'ailleurs ça pourrait
venir un peu plus rapidement
on peut le croire